I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The, ladies. Hello, everyone. Happy Wednesday. I am very excited because I absolutely love this episode. I love it so much. I kind of do.
I'm so excited to talk about it. This had remnants of the duel for me. I remember loving the duel. Yeah. It's great. I can't wait to, you know how much I loved all these scenes with Oscar. Let's get to it.
We are talking about The Target, season nine, episode eight, written by Graham Wagner and directed by Brent Forrester. Here is your summary. Oscar isn't sure if Angela knows about his affair with a senator, but in reality, oh boy does she know. And she has enlisted Dwight's help to exact her revenge. Jim is going to go to great lengths to be granted permission to work part-time and Scranton. And Pete's meaningless office task ends up being a fun project that unites his co-workers. Can I just say that Pete is the new Jim? I literally wrote down in the breakdown that I am in love with Pete.
But just how he got everyone to do this activity, it's Office Olympics. Yes. It's Jim and Office Olympics. Yes. All right, Fast Facts number one, Chris Gethard is our special guest star playing Trevor. He's so funny.
I have so many stories. We got so much mail. Fan question from Lindsay H in Tempe, Arizona, who said, I just wanted to show appreciation for the genius that is the character Trevor played by the awesome comedian Chris Gethart. He did such a great job in bodying the sort of dazed weirdo that was Trevor and was so funny
in spite of only appearing in two episodes. And then Wendy B. from Bethesda, Maryland said, I got such a kick out of Chris Gethard as Trevor. He was strange and hilarious. How did he wind up being cast? Well, Lindsay and Wendy, thanks for writing in. Yes, Chris is so amazing and very unique. And, Angela, you got to work with him. Yes. You, Chris is so amazing and very unique.
And Angela, you got to work with him. Yes. You said it was so fun. And you also reached out to him and he sent us in some audio clips. I did. He was so great. You know when you write someone
and they respond back right away and are like, yes, I'm in. Yes. That was Chris. Well, of course, the first thing we asked was, how did you get your role on The Office? And here's what he had to say. Hi, everybody, my name's Chris Gethard,
and I was really lucky to play a character named Trevor on The Office. Just for a couple episodes, but sometimes I think people think I was on it more than I was based on the amount that they talked to me about it. But it was a really lucky experience and I think about it a lot.
And I feel so lucky to be here talking about it today. How did I get my role on the office? I've never totally been sure. I auditioned, I know that much. I've always been East Coast based. I grew up in New Jersey and came up at the Upright Citizens Brigade in New York. I remember that I filmed my audition for the office at the Manhattan Neighborhood Network,
which is the public access studio in New York City. It's kind of legendarily weird, all the stuff that comes out of there. I did a talk show there for many years. I know I was on Allison Jones radar to some degree. I was actually in an improv group in New York with Bobby Moynihan and Zach Woods Zach Woods obviously played Gabe on the office and You can imagine being with those guys at UCB at the time. There was just a lot of eyes on us So mostly I just auditioned and got lucky and I've always kind of wondered who of eyes on us so mostly I just auditioned and got lucky and I've always kind of wondered who
championed me over there if it was Allison or one of the writers just because I knew a lot of people from my time in comedy. This answer is very rambly but when you ask an actor how they got a role the answer always sort of comes down to I don't know but it's some combination of UCB and having some hype from my public access show, having done a couple other things at that point in time, but mostly just auditioned and sent in a tape and then felt really lucky that they went with me. Chris, we love a rambly. Ramble as much as you want. You know what I love about that story is that we were still,
oh Sam, you are so kind. Does he bring you a tissue? He's bringing me tissue. Use your sleep. I was using my sleeve to wipe my nose and I don't, all of a sudden it started running. I don't know. It's the weather. It is.
It's the weird cold, the cold LA. It's very, what would you call it? We had frost this morning. Yeah, it's a weird cold snap that happens in the LA winter and it happens suddenly and then my nose just runs. Okay, thank you everyone. What I was gonna say was, I love the part of that story that makes it so obvious
that we were still going to New York to find actors. Like at this point, nine years in, I feel like Allison Jones could have just been phoning it in. Not Alice in Jones. No. No. She's like, I still wanna know who are the hottest people
in comedy and improv. I don't care what city they're living in. I need to see them. Yeah. That's it right there. I think mystery solved. It's Alice in Jones. It's Alice in Jones.
Just doing her job so well. And then Chris showing up. Oh, well, of course. But, you know, half of getting parts as an actor is the access, the opportunity. Getting your foot in the door. Yeah, you have to be ready, but it's my old acting teacher used to say,
success is opportunity meets readiness. You can get all the auditions in the world, but if you're not ready for them, you're not gonna go anywhere. Similarly, you can be the greatest actor in your living room, but if you have no opportunities, again, opportunity meets readiness. I think that's good for just life,
because imagine if you're going in for a job interview, it's the same thing, you can have all the skillset, but if you can't get in the room, I wanna be in the room where it happens. The room where it happens if we go back to Hamilton always always You know Angela you said that when you emailed Chris he responded right away, and he was so nice and so receptive I have to share with people that Chris told us that the reason he was so happy to send an audio clips was because you were so Nice to him on set and he never forgot it.
He actually shared that you were so nice that he was kind of confused at first because he only knew you as Angela Martin. Here is how he described it. I was on season nine and like everybody else in America, I had watched the first eight. So you do forget, like people are humans,
they're well-rounded humans, so I will say anytime Angela would ever ask me to do anything, I would of course say yes, because she was so kind on set, but it is funny because the character of Angela is not always nice, so I walked into it with some trepidation and then I had to remind myself, oh right, these people are just really good at what they do. Like I'm acting with Angela and Rain,
that is different than quote Angela and Dwight. And it was that funny thing to walk onto a set and I'd been on enough sets before that I should not have fallen for that, but just tells you how much the characters of the office seeped into our consciousness in a way just tells you how much the characters of the office seeped into our consciousness in a way that was very real and organic and genuine and where people bought it.
Cause even I, someone in comedy was like, oh right, these people are nice. They're not the characters. So I remember being so acutely aware that we were shooting inside a minivan and you two knew each other so well, and neither of you knew me. So to be in a social environment where,
not just while shooting, but in between takes, we're all just sitting in the minivan together, and you guys have like, you know, a decade of intimate knowledge of how each other's lives work, of things to chitchat about in small talk, and then I'm also just some guy. I remember that being very funny to me
and leading to some giggling. Oh my gosh, I love all of that. I know. I mean, Chris was so lovely, and I just remember him falling right into step right away. And I also remember that Rain right into step right away. And I also remember that Rain was so enamored with him. Rain was so tickled by him.
Everything he said, Rain would just get the giggles. And it was really fun. It was a fun day. Aw, I love that. I'm sure you're gonna have more stories as we break down the episode. Oh, I do. All right, Fast Fact number two, I'm calling it,
the reviews are in. Oh, your Fast Fact has two, I'm calling it, the reviews are in. Oh, your Fast Fact has a title. I titled it. Okay. We said we loved this episode. The reviewers agreed. It was a hit. But there was one thing in particular that was cited in every single review, and Angela
Kinsey, it was you. Oh, come on. Your performance. in every single review, and Angela Kinsey, it was you. Oh, come on. Your performance. And by the way, I love your performance in this episode so much. Oh my god, so much, Angela. And so it made me very excited to read all these reviews about your performance and here they are. Eric Adams, he was the new reviewer at AV Club, gave this episode an A minus and said it was your plot line with Oscar that was a season highlight, that's a quote, and he complimented you in particular
for your commitment to character. Thank you. That's not all. The paced writer called it your best performance of the year. Wow. Mm-hmm. Michael Tetter praised the writers for giving your character a chance to shine. And this was also rated the fifth best episode of the season according to fans on Office
Telly. And again, the comments cited you. You an Oscar, but you lady. Star of the episode. I don't even know what to say. That makes me, that just warms my heart. You know, when you're part of a show like The Office and there's such a deep cast of amazing people,
when you're a supporting actor, you just have to be patient and hope that someday you get your turn. And Kate Flannery and I used to talk a lot about that. You know, she would say, and we're not the meat, we're the seasoning, but the seasoning has their day. Mm-hmm.
And I was so, so delighted by the storyline and I have such fond memories of getting to do it. Well, lady, if you thought I was finished, I'm not, there's more of this fast fact. Oh, okay. Mm-hmm. In addition to reaching out to Chris Gethard, we also reached out to the director of this episode,
Brent Forester. And I have an audio clip from Brent just for you. Oh! Jenna, you mentioned that when you rewatched this episode, you were struck by how grounded the performances of the actors are. And I actually believe that the actors saved this episode because the premise is potentially so crazy, especially for a show like The Office, which is famous for having the most realistic tone of any show in the history of network TV. How do we get away with an episode in which one of the characters is threatening to assassinate the other character in The Office?
Well the answer is the performances of the actors. Somehow Rain, Oscar, and especially Angela managed to find some kind of emotional reality in the performances that ends up redeeming this zany premise so that at the end, after all this frenetic activity when Angela says to Oscar, you were supposed to be my friend, there's a feeling of real emotional tenderness there within this crazy setting. I don't know how they did it, and I wish you would ask Angela how she pulled this off. I think that's a really good analysis of why this episode works. Angela, how'd you pull it off?
Oh, gosh, that's such a big question. Well, Brent, thank you so much. You're always so generous and kind. Really, Angela Martin was a real person to me. She was. So I had to think about her life and how she tried so hard to have this persona and image of the senator's wife and what that meant to her. That status meant so much to her. And when Oscar has this affair,
someone who she trusts, who she has set next to for years and years and years, that threatens everything about who she thought she was, this image that she puts out to the world. It was all shattered. And she probably went to a pretty dark place. And Angela's dark place was, I'm gonna mess you up. But I never thought that she wanted Oscar
to be seriously injured. I think she just wanted to scare him and let him know how pissed off she was. That was sort of how I approached it. She was just hurt. She was really hurt. I mean, I think everything you just said is so emotional and real and grounded and relatable.
And that is why this premise doesn't get zany because you grounded it in all that realness. You know, it was really hard though, because I wanted to jump in and be silly, but I couldn't like, we'll get to it, but the scene in the van with the receipts, oh my gosh. Oh yeah. But I had to play it as honest as I could.
Yeah. Even though there was a little bit of Zany happening around her, she was still very hurt and angry. Those were real emotions, So I had to play them real. I just loved it so much. Thanks, lady. Thanks, everybody. All right. Moving on to Fast Facts number three. Angela, last week you had a mailbag moment,
which I loved. And I thought I might like to have a mailbag moment this week. Okay. So this will be a mailbag moment with Jenna. This is a post that I was made aware of that was on the Office Ladies Facebook fan page. It's from a poster named Chris C. And it was posted after we broke down the episode Welcome Party. That's the one where Andy and Aaron are driving back from Florida together and they decide to stop it. Jessica's parents' cabin. Yes. What was like a bachelorette party. Yes. Okay, here is what Chris
posted after that episode. I had a good laugh at this week's podcast regarding the penis cake and gummy straws. Remember we had that big conversation? Yes. Chris said, I have a ladies group and each month one of us hosts a night for just us ladies and some drinks. Somewhere along the way, I picked up a penis cake pan as a gag one night. But we've made quite the use of this pan. Now, along with the night of hosting, you are also hosting whoever's birthday it is that month and you have to make a cake out of the penis pan. I figured I'd share a few of our creations over the years.
Are there pictures? There's pictures, lady, and they're amazing. So what these ladies have to do is you have to make a cake using the penis pan, but it's not a penis. Right. So it's like, I don't know, what is it? A spaceship? Here they are.
A flying saucer? She posted a bunch of pictures. Oh my gosh. Oh, one is balloons? Mm-hmm, like a little basket? One looks like, is that a, I have to put my glasses on. I think it's like a wizard with a tall hat. Oh yeah.
Okay. Oh, flowers. Yes, so the, you know, the testicles are like a flower pot. Uh-huh. And then the top, they decorated to look like flowers. What is that one? No, not that the testicles aren't the flower pot. The tip of the penis is the flower pot.
Oh yes, I'm so sorry. And then the testicles are the flowers. Yes. But what is this? Is this a spaceship? You know what? That one got me. It really looks like a penis.
Is it a lighthouse? Is it a spaceship? Oh, no, you're right. It's a lighthouse. That's what the jelly beans are. I'm gonna put these in stories. I mean, I was hoping you would. Uh-huh.
This one is very funny, right? It's a monster. It's a one-eyed monster. Oh, and then there's corn on the cob. And there is an actual spaceship as well. Yes, and then a fruit medley. Mm-hmm, okay. I was so tickled by this.
It was the cutest idea to me. How fun. I love that these ladies do this. I was so happy that someone made me aware of this post. Thank you, Chris, for cheering. And I hope you don't mind though, we've now talked about it on the podcast and we'll be posting your penis cake photos
that are not penises. Oh my gosh. Well, on that note, I think we take a break and when we come back, Oscar is very anxious. He's waiting for Angela to show up to work. We are back and the first thing we see is an Oscar talking head. He says, yesterday Angela may or may not have figured out that I'm having an affair with her husband. So I just have to wait and see. When she comes in, if she's cold and awkward and cruel to me,
then great. It's business as usual. This is such a great opening to an episode. Like you don't need to have ever watched this show before and I'm hooked. Yeah, talk about starting in the middle. There's no back story explanation. Well, Angela's gonna arrive and I think Oscar should have known right away when she asked him about the thermostat. This is such a friendly small talk, I think. What do you think? Well, except it's a half complaint. Okay, okay.
She's a little annoyed. And so I do think that when Angela talks about something that's not work, it's probably a complaint or like she's irritated about something. Slightly irritated or very irritated. Yes. Probably is her small talk. Well, Oscar is so relieved.
Oh my gosh, she's so relieved. And talk about the reviews are in Oscar Nunez's performance. When Angela says, can I talk to you? The look on his face. He's so good. Oh, he's so good. Oscar is very good in this episode. The two of you are such a good team.
I would like to point out in the background of the scene that Kate Flannery is making some major solitaire moves. She's moving things around, things are shuffling, whole decks. Oh, wow. Yeah, she was crushing it that day. Well, now Oscar's gonna have a talking head and he's thrilled. Yeah.
Angela doesn't know. It's great. However, then we see over his shoulder in the background, Angela just glaring at him, gripping some scissors. Oh yeah. This is how it read in the shooting draft. The camera finds Angela over Oscar's shoulder glaring at him with murderous intent. You did it. I remember doing this a few times and they were like Angela even meaner glare more glare meaner. I'm like, I don't know. I'm giving it all I got here.
Also, you might have caught that Stanley is not at his desk during Oscar's talking head, which is very rare. Stanley is almost always out of dash. Well, I have a little call sheet tidbit for you that will explain why. Please. We filmed the scene on the first day of filming on Monday, October 22nd, 2012, and the only people called to set that day were me, Oscar, Rain and Chris Gethard.
Oh. We stacked all of our scenes together on that one day, and so the rest of the cast had the day off. Nice. Yes. And in case you were wondering, the high that day was 71 degrees. Oh, pleasant. There's your weather report.
One other little thing on the call sheets this week is in the top right corner, there was a little pumpkin with a countdown to Halloween. Hmm. So cute. So cute. Those are my call sheet tidbits, but I also have a big reveal from the shooting draft. A big reveal? Yes. What is it? Okay. Do you remember the holiday that we have always said was missing on the office? Thanksgiving? Yes, lady. There was a whole Thanksgiving cold open. Oh, because we were shooting this in late October, but it would have aired around Thanksgiving?
Yes! And we actually filmed a Thanksgiving cold open that didn't make it. A lot of it is in deleted scenes, but I wanted to read you how it started in the shooting draft. Interior conference room. Darryl and Toby are leading a meeting. A stack of assorted canned foods is presented on a table. Toby says, thank you all for participating in this year's Thanksgiving canned food drive. I remember this. The staff.
It's so funny. And then it says, the staff all applauds itself. We're very pleased with what we've donated. But then Darrell starts looking at what all the people brought in to donate. It is so funny, he starts calling people out. He's like Phyllis, you brought in water chestnuts. Meredith also water chestnuts.
Creed brought in a can of garbanzo beans dated 1990. Someone else brought in racquetballs and Daryl is getting so annoyed. Then he holds up a can and says, I don't even know what this is. And Kevin says, it's brown. And Darrell's like, what? Kevin then has a talking head where he says,
I eat brown every week. Hot brown, ice brown, scrambled brown. And then he holds up a can that has a little pig on it. And in Russian, it says dog food. Yes, I so remember this. And then Toby gets upset. He says, you know what? I have a solution for your poor participation
in this canned food drive. Instead of going home early today, we'll be having a little Thanksgiving feast of our own, made with your canned food. And Kevin at first was like, yes. And then when Toby says with your canned food, Kevin goes, you son of a bitch. Then there's a whole montage of the Dunder Mifflin crew
making this Thanksgiving lunch out of these lame can contributions. And here's how the scene ends. I want you to hear it. Happy Thanksgiving. And remember, you did this to yourselves. I think everybody learned a valuable lesson. And if I had a Thanksgiving meal with other people for the first time in years,
well, good for me. Toby! So we did have a Thanksgiving episode. This would have been it. Wow. Our only nod to Thanksgiving and it got cut out. That's right. Well, I think there was just too much good stuff in this episode. Yeah. That we just didn't have room for a cold open. We start right with the plot.
Yep. But there's a bunch in deleted scenes, so if you have the DVDs, you can go watch them. Well, now Pam and Jim are going to arrive to the office, and Pam is wearing her painting clothes, because she's going to finally start on the mural in the warehouse. Meredith has such sidebar sass. She goes Queen of the Primer this one. Yeah she asked Pam, you sure you don't want to put another coat of primer on it? Queen of the Primer. We had a fan question from Colleen S. in Chicago who said, do you have any stories behind Pam's painting clothes? The outfit was auctioned off after the series ended and I ended up winning it. Jenna, if you would like to have it back,
I would be more than happy to send it to you. Colleen, I have to tell you something. I have one too. There were multiples. All of our outfits, we had more than one. We had doubles in case we spilled something on it or something happened. So I have one of the sweatshirts and you must have the other one. So I have one of the Pratt sweatshirts with all the paint on it. And this was just the idea of Alicia Raycraft, our costume designer.
She came and she said, what do you think Pam's painting clothes are? And she had this idea and I loved this callback to her time at Pratt. I just absolutely loved it. So creative. It also looks like a very cozy sweatshirt. Oh, I loved this outfit. I bet.
No pantyhose. You got to wear jeans. Jeans. I can't believe you wore pantyhose for nine years. I know. Four times. I didn't wear them one day. Every time you say it, it hurts me.
Every time. I just shoved him aside and no one said anything. I don't know, I'm a rule follower. You are. Jim and Pam are now gonna have a joint talking head and Jim explains that he has to ask David Wallace if he can start working part time because his sports marketing team really needs him.
He also shares in his absence, they named the company, Athlete. While he wasn't there, he was like, I could have prevented that if I had been there. Yeah. I guess Jim doesn't like the name. I like Athlete. I don't, I think it's terrible.
Oh really? I was like- It's like so, it's so well chosen that it's a bad name. It's hard to say athlete. I don't like it. Athlete. It sounds like athlete's foot to me. I don't know, but then it's elite.
I don't get it. I don't like the play on words. We had a fan question from Chaley Dee in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania, who said, were there any other ideas for the name of the company? There must have been so many. I asked Brent, he said, there were so many names I asked Brent, he said there were so many names. He said writers love riffing on dumb names.
And here are a few. Winnovate. Okay. Champlify. That's funny. And gosh, I don't even know how to say this one. Jock-a-tagon. What? Can I see it?
Yeah, I think it's like octagon, but it's jock-a-tagon. Like a jockstrap? I don't know. I think like jock like athlete. Oh, like an athlete. Jock-a-tagon. There's no V in it, lady. It's jock-a-tagon. Oh, jock-a-tagon. Yeah. Did I say von every time? That last time you did. Yeah, I did the last time. Jock-a-tagon, like octagon. Yeah. I like Champlify. That to me would have hit the joke harder than athlete, but maybe it's too ridiculous. Well, athlete is a better name than Champlify. Yeah.
But Champlify is very funny to say. It is. Lady, I have a tangent that just popped into my head. It is in no way related to this episode. In fact, it's related to an episode of The Crown. Oh, I'm taking, I don't, are you kidding? The Crown, I don't mind. I'm taking off my glasses.
I'm getting my cup of tea. Let's hear it. Okay. This is totally unplanned. Okay. It's not in my document. I know it's not. Okay.
The other night, Lee and I were watching The Crown, the latest season, the final season. Yeah. And I'm on the episode where Prince William has gone to college and he goes out to a party one night and they do beer bongs. Yeah. Have you ever done a beer bong? Cause I haven't.
And as I was watching it, I was like, who wants to do that? It looks awful. It looks like torture. No, I've never done it. The closest I've come to that is in college I played on a co-ed softball team and at second base, they had a pony keg. And if you made it to second base, you could do a keg stand. What's a keg stand?
You do a handstand. Oh, this is worse. This is getting worse. On top of a keg and then there's a little hose and they put beer. You have to drink upside down? Yeah, I did a keg stand anyway. I've done that. But it just, basically it just goes all over your face and you know, you're just like,
this is stupid. But I was in college. I have not done, what's it called? A beer pong? A beer pong. Oh, a beer pong. Beer pong? Bong.
Why would I think it was beer pong? Well there's a game called beer pong. Oh. Where you try to get a ping pong ball into bong. Bong. Why would I think it was beer pong? Well, there's a game called beer pong. Oh, where you try to get a ping pong ball into a thing of beer and then you have to chug it. I did that, but on a TV show and they were like, Angela, we want you to toss this ping pong ball into the cup of beer. And they're like, we'll roll a few because you probably won't get it, you know, right away. I got it on the first take. Was it real beer? Was it like a reality thing?
No, it was fakey. Oh, it was for a scripted show. It was the show I did with Kate Walsh, bad judge. Okay. But I made the ping pong in the red solo cup on my first try. I think I could be good at it. So wait, when you play beer pong,
you throw the ball and you're trying to get it in the cup so that you can chug it? No, the other person has to chug it? I think it's the other person. Right, because if I were playing that, I would just always miss because I would never want to chug the beer. So I fake played beer pong, but never played it in real life.
I have done a keg stand playing softball, but I've never done a beer bong. It looks difficult. When I was a freshman in college, like the first two weeks of school, me and some of the other gals on my floor at my dorm, we got invited to a frat party. Oh gosh.
I went to it for less than an hour and never went to another one again. I was like, I don't get it. This is not for me. I am confused by all of the activities. None of them seem fun. I am very anxious at this event. And then later when I was an upperclassman,
like there was a group of guys in the theater department who had a theater fraternity. And I was like, maybe that's my jam. I know all these guys, I'm doing plays with these guys. Yeah. And you didn't have to be in the theater department to be in that fraternity, but it was sort of like you were. I went to that one and I was like,
就像剧组里有一群人搞了个戏剧兄弟会。然后我就想，也许那挺适合我的。这些人我都认识，我也跟他们一起排话剧。对啊。而且你不用非得是戏剧系的人才能进那个兄弟会，但感觉就像是那样。我去了那个地方，然后我想，
I don't know what's happened to all of these people who I adore while we're doing theater, but now I can't, it's a culture that I, Yeah. I just, I don't, it's a culture that I, I don't know what's happening here, but I didn't, so I'm watching the crown, and I'm watching the beer bonging. Okay. And I was like, I've never done,
我不知道这些我平时排戏时特别喜欢的人到底怎么了，但现在我……那是一种我，对啊。我就是，我不知道，那是一种我……我不知道这儿在发生什么，但我不想，所以我正在看《王冠》，然后我看着他们玩啤酒喷泉。好吧。然后我就想，我从来没做过，
there's nothing from the time I was born in my DNA that could get myself to do this activity. Yeah, no. And it's very popular popular and many people do it and I guess are enjoying it and having fun, but I can't. I don't get it, I don't like. I got it. I've never done a beerbong.
我从出生到现在，基因里就没有哪部分能让我去做这种活动。对，没错。而且这非常受欢迎，很多人都这么干，我想他们也很享受、玩得很开心，但我做不到。我不理解，我不喜欢。我明白了。我从来没玩过啤酒喷泉。
I've had no desire. I've seen people do them around me. My college didn't have sorority and fraternity houses. So a lot of that like kind of big frat party thing wasn't part of my college, but I do notice that like, if I do have a story, it's around like a sport. It's like softball or football game,
我一点兴趣都没有。我见周围的人玩过。我的大学里没有兄弟会和姐妹会宿舍。所以那种大型兄弟会派对的氛围其实并不是我大学生活的一部分。不过我确实注意到，如果我真有什么故事，那也是围绕着某项运动。比如垒球或橄榄球比赛，
but I don't like chugging stuff. I don't like speeding up the getting drunk process, right? Like I don't, I haven't gone out for the purpose of getting drunk super fast.? Like I don't, I haven't gone out for the purpose of getting drunk super fast. I probably shouldn't have told you I brought shots for us today. Shots, shots, shots, shots, shots.
但我讨厌狂灌东西。我不喜欢加速喝醉的过程，对吧？我不……我从来没有为了快速喝醉而特地出门。？我从来没有为了快速喝醉而特地出门。我大概不该告诉你们我今天给我们带了烈酒。干杯，干杯，干杯，干杯，干杯。
No. Okay. Sorry for that tangent. It just popped into my head. I doubled down on your tangent. I could have just said, no, I've never done one. We'd be done with this conversation. Well, let me tell you what I would love to do
不。好吧。抱歉扯远了。我脑子里突然冒出来的。我还顺着你的话继续往下聊了。我本来大可以说“不，我从来没玩过”，然后这天就聊完了。好吧，那我来告诉你我最想做的事
as an activity at a party is build a giant card wall. I would too. I would love that. That's my jam. They're really hard to do. I've tried to do it with the deck of cards before. I know. And they're real slick.
作为派对活动，那就是搭一座巨型纸牌屋。我也想。我太想了。那太对我的胃口了。那东西可真难搭。我以前用一副扑克牌试过。我知道。而且牌特别滑。
You need an old deck. What? What? What? What? I don't know, lady. I don't know that just the... It's just the... Just like the earnestness and authority
你需要一副旧牌。什么？什么？什么？什么？我不知道，女士。我不知道，只是那个……就是那个……就是那种一本正经的语气和权威感，
with which you have given us this tip on how to build a successful card tower. You need an old deck. They can't be shiny or slick. I noted that Pete used these complaint cards and I looked at them and they are like the rougher card stock. They're not the slick paper. I'm just saying. More successful tower.
你用这种语气给我们传授如何成功搭起纸牌屋的秘诀。你需要一副旧牌。它们不能太亮或者太滑。我注意到皮特用的是这些投诉卡，我看了看，它们的卡纸质地比较粗糙。不是那种光滑的纸。我只是随口说说。这样塔才能搭得更成功。
That's right. Well, let's tell you why Pete is going to start a tower. He's not starting it yet, but he has a talking head where he says he's been tasked with entering customer complaints into a computer. And then after that, he has to fill out a comment card. He asked Andy, why do I have to do this? They're already in the computer. And Andy said, chillax.
没错。好吧，让我们来告诉你为什么皮特要开始搭纸牌屋了。他现在还没开始，但有一个他的单人采访，里面说他的任务是把客户投诉录入电脑。然后在那之后，他还得填一张意见卡。他问安迪，为什么我非得做这个？它们不是已经在电脑里了吗？安迪说，放松点。
And then went on a big boat ride. Yes. So he's decided that he's gonna use the cards. He's gonna give them purpose and he's gonna build a paper tower. Yeah. He says, don't give me a pointless office chore because I will build a little paper house.
然后就坐着大船兜风去了。对。所以他决定要利用这些卡片。他要赋予它们意义，他要用纸搭一座塔。对。他说，别给我派那些毫无意义的办公室杂务，因为我会用纸搭一座小房子。
Fight the power. I love him. I do too. Angela now approaches Dwight. Oh, sabotage in the break room. Sabotage in the break room. She says, meet me at the old place in five minutes. I need you.
反抗强权。我太爱他了。我也是。安吉拉现在走向德怀特。哦，茶水间的蓄意破坏。茶水间的蓄意破坏。她说，五分钟后老地方见。我需要你。
And then she goes down to their warehouse spot and she opens up that door and he is completely nudy. He is naked. With his leg up and his bits dangling. Oh yeah, she says, Dwight, please put your clothes back on. It's not that kind of meeting. And then she says, I need someone who can operate outside of the law. And Dwight says, nope, you lost those privileges.
然后她走到他们的仓库区域，推开那扇门，结果他一丝不挂。他全裸着。一条腿抬着，命根子就那么晃荡着。哦对，她说，德怀特，请把衣服穿上。这不是那种会面。然后她说，我需要一个能游走于法律之外的人。德怀特说，不行，你已经失去这种特权了。
If I'm not in your panties, I don't go vigilantes. You've got to know. Some writer pitched that, and when it made it in, it was just like so tickled. Yes, we should have asked Brent about that. That's a really funny line. It is. Angela then confesses to Dwight that her marriage
如果我不能睡你，我就不去当义警。你得明白。某个编剧提出了这个点子，当它真的被采用时，大家觉得太逗了。对，我们本来该问问布伦特的。那真是一句搞笑的台词。确实如此。安吉拉接着向德怀特坦白，她的婚姻
is in danger, she doesn't know who she can trust. Dwight says, you know, I know just the guy, the former cop who was kicked off the force. And then he says, I'm going to SMS text him to set up a meeting. Gets back to him right away. No problem. He's free anytime. Yeah. Well, now Jim is on the phone with David Wallace.
陷入了危机，她不知道自己还能信任谁。德怀特说，你知道吗，我刚好知道这么个人，那个被警局开除的前警察。然后他说，我要给他发短信安排个会面。马上就回信了。没问题。他随时都有空。好吧，现在吉姆正在和大卫·华莱士打电话。
He's doing this phone call at his desk because Jim doesn't know how to make phone calls more private. No, he doesn't. He learned that. No, he's not going to have a private conversation. And Jim is like, listen, it'll just be a couple days a week that I would be in Philly. I'd be in Scranton the other days and what do you think? And David Wallace is kind of like, I don't know, Jim. It kind of seems like
他坐在自己的办公桌前打这通电话，因为吉姆不知道怎么让电话变得更私密一些。不，他不知道。他算是学到了。不，他可不会进行私人谈话。吉姆就说，听着，我一周只需要去费城几天。其他几天我都在斯克兰顿，你觉得怎么样？大卫·华莱士就觉得，我不知道，吉姆。这感觉好像
what if something goes down and needs someone there in person to deal with it? Yeah. So Jim lies. In the moment, he says, oh, Phyllis and Stanley offered to cover for me. And David's like, oh, well, if that's the case, okay. I will point out, I think David Wallace
万一出了什么状况，需要有人当面处理怎么办？对。所以吉姆撒谎了。他当即说道，哦，菲莉丝和斯坦利答应帮我代班。大卫就说，哦，既然这样的话，那好吧。我要指出的是，我觉得大卫·华莱士
might be the most lax boss ever. Yeah. Andy's off on a boat, no problem. Yeah. Jim's like, I want to only be part time but pay me the same. He's like, okay. Yeah. We should all work for David Wallace.
可能是史上最随性的老板了。对。安迪坐船去了，没问题。对。吉姆说，我想只做兼职但拿一样的工资。他直接说，好吧。对。我们都该为大卫·华莱士打工。
No kidding. We had a fan question from Emily J. in Ohio who said, is Pam not a salesman at all anymore? Why does Jim need Phyllis and Stanley to cover? Can't Pam cover? Emily made a good point. I think I'm trying to remember back when Pam became the office administrator.
真的假的。我们收到了来自俄亥俄州埃米莉·J.的粉丝提问，她说，帕姆现在是不是完全不做销售了？为什么吉姆需要菲莉丝和斯坦利代班？帕姆不能代班吗？埃米莉问得好。我想我得回想一下帕姆是什么时候当上办公室行政主管的。
I think she was still gonna keep her couple of clients that she had. She still does a little sales, right? Oh, I thought she was done. I thought she created a new position and she was no longer part of the sales team. That's how I saw it. I couldn't remember. But let's say like, sure, she does still do a little bit of sales. I think the question is, do you want Pam covering for you? She was the worst salesperson. I'm not sure David Wallace is going to let Jim go to Philly a couple days a week if the backup is Pam.
我想她当时还是会保留她手头的那几个客户。她还是会做一点销售，对吧？哦，我还以为她不做了呢。我以为她创造了一个新职位，然后就不再是销售团队的一员了。我是这么理解的。我记不清了。不过就算她确实还做一点销售吧，我觉得问题在于，你想让帕姆帮你代班吗？她可是最差的销售员。我不确定如果备选是帕姆的话，大卫·华莱士会不会同意吉姆一周去费城几天。
I don't know, I'm just saying, you know, no offense to Pam, but like, this is the- Sales are not her thing. Sales were not her thing. We don't have to all be good at everything all the time. No, we don't. It's okay, Pam.
我不知道，我只是随口一说，对帕姆没有恶意，但这就是——销售不适合她。销售根本不适合她。我们没必要随时随地把所有事情都做好。没错，没必要。没关系，帕姆。
Yeah, we love you. Well, now we go back to the break room. Stanley and Phyllis are there and Jim comes in and really wants them to help him. He says, hey, we're friends, right? And Stanley's like, we're not friends. Yeah, Stanley's like, if we were friends, when's my birthday, Jim? And Jim is like, when's my birthday? And Stanley says, I have no idea because we're not friends. You know, every single person wrote in about this to remind us that in season eight episode ten, Jim says
对，我们爱妳。好吧，现在我们回到茶水间。斯坦利和菲莉丝在那儿，吉姆走过去，非常希望他们能帮帮他。他说，嘿，我们是朋友，对吧？斯坦利却说，我们不是朋友。对，斯坦利就说，如果我们是朋友，吉姆，我的生日是什么时候？吉姆就说，那我的生日是什么时候？斯坦利说，我根本不知道，因为我们不是朋友。你知道吗，每个人都写信来提醒我们这件事，在第八季第十集里，吉姆说过
he got Stanley tickets to a comedy show for his birthday. So Jim knows Stanley's birthday. Or he's certainly celebrated it before. He must have a general idea of what it is. Well Jim is going to offer to take them to lunch to discuss it further and now they're in. They're up for free lunch. They're interested.
他送过斯坦利喜剧秀的门票作为生日礼物。所以吉姆其实知道斯坦利的生日。或者他以前肯定庆祝过。他心里大概有个数到底是什么时候。好吧，吉姆提出要请他们吃午餐以便进一步商量，现在他们上钩了。他们愿意为了免费午餐去。他们感兴趣了。
Yeah. Yeah. further, and now they're in. They're up for free lunch. They're interested, yes. Outside Dwight and Angela are walking down the sidewalk when Dwight shoves Angela into a van and we meet Trevor. Call sheet tidbit, this was the very first scene filmed on the very first day of filming, so Chris as the guest star was first up. Wow, right? Trevor says, is it safe to talk?
对。对。步，现在他们上钩了。他们愿意为了免费午餐去。他们感兴趣了，对。在外面，德怀特和安吉拉正走在人行道上，突然德怀特把安吉拉推进了一辆面包车，我们见到了特雷弗。通告单花絮，这是第一天拍摄的第一场戏，所以作为客串明星的克里斯是第一个上场的。哇，对吧？特雷弗说，现在说话安全吗？
Dwight says, well, this documentary crew has been following our every move for the past nine years, but I don't see him, so I think we're good. Angela's gonna ask Trevor, what are your credentials? And this line made me laugh so hard. I broke when he said it the first time. With super seriousness, Trevor says, I started following people around to get exercise. Turns out I'm damn good at it.
德怀特说，这个纪录片摄制组过去九年来一直在跟踪我们的一举一动，但我没看见他们，所以我觉得没问题。安吉拉问特雷弗，你有什么资质？这句话把我逗得前仰后合。他第一次说的时候我就笑喷了。特雷弗一本正经地说，我开始跟着别人是为了锻炼身体。结果发现我特么还挺擅长这个。
I lost it. Yes. Next question, they would like to know if he has a gun. And he's like, do I have a gun? And he pulls out a receipt. He says, read the receipt. And Angela's has a gun and he's like, do I have a gun? Check this out. He pulls out a receipt. He says, read the receipt. And Angela's like, what? You don't carry it with you? And he's like, it's expensive. Someone could steal it. And then Dwight says, you have no idea how many guns Trevor's had stolen. And Trevor's like, yeah, now I keep it in a safe and then shows them the
我直接笑疯了。对。下一个问题，他们想知道他有没有枪。然后他说，我有没有枪？他掏出一张收据。他说，看收据。然后安吉拉有把枪，他说，我有没有枪？看看这个。他掏出一张收据。他说，看收据。安吉拉说，什么？你不随身带着吗？他说，这很贵。别人会偷走的。然后德怀特说，你根本不知道特雷弗被偷过多少支枪。特雷弗就说，对啊，现在我把它锁在保险箱里，然后向他们展示了
receipt of the safe. This is something I have to share with you guys. This receipts bit went on for so long. Were there more receipts? Chris started improvising. You saw how many papers he's holding in his hands? Yes. He just started improvising all the different things he has receipts for. Oh my God.
保险箱的收据。这件事我得跟你们分享一下。这个收据的梗演了太久了。还有更多收据吗？克里斯开始即兴发挥。你们看到他手里拿了多少纸吗？是的。他开始即兴发挥他所有保留着收据的各种东西。天哪。
I was crying. I was laughing. I was laughing. I was so hoping that I would find them in the bloopers or something. I know they're out there somewhere, but oh my gosh, we did a lot of takes and each time he had more receipts for things. Well, you know, one of the things he shared with us
我都笑哭了。我当时在笑。我太希望能在花絮里找到这些了。我知道它们肯定在某处，但天哪，我们拍了好多条，每一次他拿出来的收据都更多。好吧，你知道他跟我们分享的事其中之一
was that when he runs into people who recognize him, they always say, check your receipts. Yes. And he's always like, wait, what? Oh, oh. Yes, check your receipts is his safe bandit or don't throw garbage at me. Exactly. That's what perfect strangers say to him as he's walking through an airport. Well now we're going to go to the warehouse as Pam prepares to start painting.
就是当他在路上遇到认出他的人时，他们总是说，查收据。是的。而他总是说，等等，什么？哦，哦。是的，“查收据”就是他的安全暗号，或者“别朝我扔垃圾”。没错。这就是素不相识的人在机场走过时对他说的话。好吧，现在我们要去仓库，帕姆准备开始画画了。
She's up on this big, what do you call that thing, like a scaffolding? Yeah, it's like a scaffolding. Yeah. And she's put a grid up in pencil and she's looking at her sketches. She's getting prepared. She's going to start this. Yeah. She says, you know what?
她站在那个巨大的……你管那个叫什么，有点像脚手架的东西上？对，就像脚手架。对。她用铅笔打好了网格，正在看着她的草图。她在做准备。她要开始动工了。对。她说，你知道吗？
If I mess up, I can just cover it with a shrub. Yeah. This talking head of Pam's was actually longer by one sentence and it cracked me up. Here's how it read in the shooting draft. I guess if I make a mistake, I can just cover it up with a shrub or something. But I always think less of paintings that are full of shrubs. I'm only allowing myself one shrub. And then here's the line that she would have said,
如果我搞砸了，我可以用一丛灌木把它盖住。对。帕姆的这段单人采访其实多了一句话，把我逗得不行。拍摄剧本里是这么写的：我想如果我犯了错误，我可以用一丛灌木或其他什么东西把它盖住。但我总是觉得画满了灌木的画很低级。我只允许自己画一丛灌木。然后是她原本要说的话，
two shrubs and a guy with a big umbrella, tops. Nice. I thought it was so cute. From down below, Hida is watching, and Pam is just like, go back to work. It's like she feels this pressure that he's just watching and watching. He says he'd prefer to wait.
两丛灌木和一个撑着大伞的人，不能再多了。太可爱了。我觉得这太可爱了。从下面看，日出正在看着，帕姆就说，回去工作吧。就好像她感到了压力，因为他一直在那儿看啊看。他说他更愿意等着。
Well, guess what? There was a lot more of Pam and Hida, and talk about the pairing. I need more of. It is so funny. There's a bunch of deleted scenes. First of all, do you know what the warehouse workers call Pam? It's in deleted scenes. I want you to hear it. It's a lot of pressure. People work in this warehouse every day and I don't want them to look up and say, boy, that Pat really screwed up this one. A lot of the people who work in the warehousing, my name is Pat.
好吧，你猜怎么着？帕姆和日出还有更多互动，说到这对组合。我需要看更多。太搞笑了。有很多删减片段。首先，你知道仓库工人们管帕姆叫什么吗？这在删减片段里。我想让你们听听。压力太大了。每天都有人在这个仓库工作，我可不想他们抬起头来说，天哪，那个帕特这回可把事情搞砸了。很多在仓库工作的人……我叫帕特。
I thought that was so funny. So funny. They all think your name is Pat. And then Hideo has a talking head. He has some insights on Pat. So many things. More sc and painting. Japanese government. Chinese Navy. What is Pat afraid of? Pat afraid of... Pat! Pat's afraid of Pat. Pat is afraid of Pat! Listen, that's what stops most of us most of the time. Yeah. It's just the fear, the fear of failure, the fear of things not turning out the way you hoped. Pat is afraid of Pat. You know, when I gave myself permission
我觉得这太搞笑了。太搞笑了。他们都以为你叫帕特。然后日出有一段单人采访。他对帕特有一些独到的见解。好多东西。更多的场景和绘画。日本政府。中国海军。帕特怕什么？帕特怕……帕特！帕特怕帕特。帕特怕帕特！听着，这就是大多数人大多数时候停滞不前的原因。对。就是恐惧，对失败的恐惧，对事情没有按你希望的那样发展的恐惧。帕特怕帕特。你知道，当我允许自己
to do things imperfectly, my career started to take off. It's not a weird thing. It was like, I found that, by the way, artist's way. Artist's way. Can I do it imperfectly? Yeah. Can I finish it? And it might be crap?
把事情做得不完美时，我的事业开始腾飞了。这并不是一件很怪的事。就好像，我发现，顺便说一句，《艺术家之路》。《艺术家之路》。我可以做得不完美吗？对。我可以把它完成吗？哪怕它是个烂摊子？
That's a thing. The first thing you write the first time you do the scene, it's gonna be crap. You know what I mean? It's like, you're not Rembrandt with the first painting. Right. You have to have a bunch of crap first. So make the crap. Do the crap.
这也是一种情况。你写的第一样东西，你第一次拍这场戏的时候，肯定是个烂摊子。你知道我的意思吗？就好像，你画第一幅画的时候可不是伦勃朗。没错。你得先产出一堆烂摊子。所以去制造烂摊子吧。去搞砸吧。
Do the crap. Write the crappy novel or short story or whatever, you'll revise it 50 times and then it'll be great. That's right. I even look at these scenes, you know, this episode as we break it down. And I just remember how many times we would have to do things to get it right.
去搞砸吧。写那本烂小说、烂短篇故事或者别的什么，你修改个五十遍，它就会变得很棒。没错。我甚至看着这些场景，你知道的，当我们把这集拆解开来时。我就想起我们为了拍好它，得拍多少遍。
Oh yeah. That's the kind of cool magic of film and television is that someone watches the final performance. Yeah. They take, they- You don't know how long it took to get there. That's right. And someone watches the final performance. Yeah. They take- You don't know how long it took to get there. That's right. And they use the best take.
哦，对。这就是电影和电视那种酷炫的魔力所在，那就是观众看到的是最终的成品。对。他们花时间——你根本不知道为了达到那个效果花了多长时间。没错。而且观众看到的是最终的成品。对。他们花时间——你根本不知道为了达到那个效果花了多长时间。没错。而且他们用的是最好的一条。
Exactly. Back in the van, Dwight tells Trevor that he'll be paid half now and half upon completion of the job. Obviously, off the books. Nice. No taxes. Yeah. Angela hands him an envelope with all the pertinent information.
没错。回到车里，德怀特告诉特雷弗，他将先拿到一半报酬，剩下的一半在工作完成后支付。很明显，走私下账。不错。不用交税。对。安吉拉递给他一个装有所有相关信息的信封。
But what's the job? Murder. Murder! Yeah, this is even too much for Dwight, right? Yeah, mm-hmm. He pulls Angela aside, they're on the sidewalk. He says, you cannot have someone murdered. And she explains to him that the target
但工作是什么？谋杀。谋杀！是的，这甚至对德怀特来说都太过火了，对吧？对，嗯嗯。他把安吉拉拉到一边，在人行道上。他说，你不能找人谋杀。而安吉拉向他解释说，目标
is sleeping with her husband. And he says, I'm so sorry, but this is just crazy. You can't do this. Trevor's up for it. Trevor's like, I think I can do it. It's so crazy. I know. I know. Dwight says, listen, there are different ways to get revenge, like defecating in a paper bag. Trevor quickly says, I've been on the receiving end of that a few times and it's devastating. I've been on the receiving end of that a few times and it's devastating. That's another line that made me laugh.
正和她的丈夫睡觉。而他说，我很抱歉，但这实在是太疯狂了。你不能这么做。特雷弗倒是很乐意。特雷弗说，我觉得我能行。这太疯狂了。我知道。我知道。德怀特说，听着，复仇有很多种方式，比如在纸袋里大便。特雷弗迅速接话道，我好几次都成了那个受害者，那打击真是毁灭性的。我好几次都成了那个受害者，那打击真是毁灭性的。这也是一句让我笑出声的台词。
What they decide on is that Trevor is going to damage Oscars kneecaps. Yeah, a kneecapping. Yeah, hit him in the kneecaps. It's going to happen at 4 p.m. No turning back once Trevor leaves. That's right. Fan question from Jenna F. in Los Angeles. Angela, Chris talked about being in the van all together with you guys shooting these scenes.
他们最终决定让特雷弗去废了奥斯卡的膝盖骨。对，打碎膝盖。对，打他的膝盖骨。这将在下午4点发生。特雷弗一旦离开就没回头路了。没错。来自洛杉矶詹娜·F.的粉丝提问。安吉拉，克里斯谈到和你们大家一起挤在面包车里拍这些戏。
Can you please share about doing these? These were so great. I mean, how did you get through these? Almost everything he said made me laugh because he said it was such earnestness. This character Trevor is such like a funny guy. but there was one moment that really got me and it's actually in deleted scenes. I'm not going to play it, Jenna, because it's more of a sight gag.
能跟我们分享一下拍这些戏的经历吗？这些戏太棒了。我是说，你们是怎么坚持拍完的？他说的几乎每句话都把我逗笑了，因为他说得太一本正经了。特雷弗这个角色真的是个很有趣的人。但有一个瞬间真的戳中了我的笑点，其实它在删减片段里。詹娜，我不打算放出来了，因为它更像是一个视觉笑话。
Oh, okay. But I have to share it in stories. I have to. So, there's this very serious moment in the van and Angela Martin says to Trevor, what do you do if you get caught? And then he says, I slipped through people's fingers. And then Dwight tries to grab him and he does this hand move and Dwight's like, I can't get him.
哦，好吧。但我必须在故事里分享它。我必须这么做。所以，面包车里有一个非常严肃的时刻，安吉拉·马丁对特雷弗说，如果你被抓了怎么办？然后他说，我从人们的指缝间溜走。接着德怀特试图抓住他，他做了个手部动作，德怀特就说，我抓不住他。
I can't get him. And then totally improvised, Rain's like, you go, you try Angela. So then I just start trying to grab him and Chris's Trevor just keeps doing these moves and then I'm like, I can't get them. And Chris's Trevor just keeps doing these moves and then I'm like, ah, can't get him. Anyway, we ended up cracking up at how ridiculous me and Rain trying to grab Chris and him doing these ridiculous hand moves.
我抓不住他。然后完全是即兴的，雷恩就说，你去，安吉拉你试试。然后我就开始试着去抓他，而克里斯演的特雷弗就一直在做这些动作，然后我就说，啊，抓不住他。而克里斯演的特雷弗就一直在做这些动作，然后我就说，啊，抓不住他。总之，我们最后因为我和雷恩试图抓克里斯而他却做着那些滑稽的手部动作而笑得前仰后合。
And he's like, slips through your fingers, can't get me. It was just such silly physical gags, but we just lost it. Oh my gosh, I wish that was in the episode. That sounds so funny. Imagine Angela trying, we were like tussling. Like I'm trying to grab him and he's like swatting at me. But we're seated in a van.
他就说，从你们指缝间溜走，抓不到我。那只是一些非常愚蠢的肢体笑话，但我们直接笑场了。天哪，我真希望这一段能剪进正片里。听起来太逗了。想象一下安吉拉去试，我们当时就像在扭打。就像我试图抓住他，而他在挥舞着双手拍打我。但我们是坐在面包车里的。
I mean, amazing. Amazing. It was such a fun day. Well, there was another thing that Chris shared with us that I found so relatable and so charming. This was about just a memory he had of being on the office. Here's what he said.
我的天，太棒了。太棒了。那是极其欢乐的一天。好吧，克里斯跟我们分享的另一件事让我觉得特别有共鸣，也特别有魅力。这只是关于他在《办公室》当中的一段记忆。他是这么说的。
Another thing I remember is that the office got me glasses to my actual prescription. And I think in my entire career of acting, that's the only time that a set has gone above and beyond like that. It's really, really thoughtful to do. I get a lot of parts as guys in glasses, like weird guys in glasses. And sometimes they make me wear my own glasses. And then a lot of times they want you to wear like slightly weirder glasses. And that just means I'm blind. It means on a lot of sets. Like honestly, anytime you've ever seen me acting if I'm wearing glasses that aren't mine I'm just blind except the office. The office contacted me ahead of time and got my prescription and had a few sets of glasses made with my prescription so I'm wearing
我记得的另一件事是，《办公室》剧组按照我真实的视力度数给我配了眼镜。我想在我整个演艺生涯中，这是唯一一次有剧组能做到这种超越常规的程度。这真的，真的很贴心。我经常接到戴眼镜的角色，比如戴眼镜的怪人。有时他们让我戴我自己的眼镜。但很多时候，他们希望你戴那种看起来稍微更古怪一点的眼镜。而那意味着我成了瞎子。这意味着在很多剧组里。老实说，只要你看到我演戏时戴着不是我自己的眼镜，除了《办公室》之外，我其实都是个瞎子。《办公室》提前联系了我，拿到了我的视力处方，并按照我的处方专门配了好几副眼镜，所以我
these big goofy glasses in the show and they got my actual prescription and I can tell you that's above and beyond and extraordinarily thoughtful because I don't When someone calls cut and there's a million moving parts and you're just a guest star And you have to be like can somebody find the PA who took my glasses because you literally can't walk ten feet without banging into something or like knocking into a piece of equipment without it like You do feel like really stranded out there on a set So the fact that the office got my prescription and made those glasses real was shocking
在剧里戴着这些又大又滑稽的眼镜，而且它们是根据我真正的视力处方配的，我可以告诉你，这已经超越了本职工作，而且极其贴心，因为我……当导演喊“咔”的时候，现场有成百万个移动的部件，而你只是个客串演员，你得去找那个拿了你眼镜的制片助理，因为你简直连走十英尺都做不到，就会撞到什么东西，或者撞到某件设备，如果没有这个的话……你真的会觉得自己被孤立在片场了。所以《办公室》能拿到我的视力处方并把那些眼镜做成真眼镜，这真的太让人震惊了，
and really cool and thoughtful and nice. Well, Angela, we know who that is. We know who did that. Phil. That's Phil. Yeah. And I'm gonna get choked up. I know.
而且真的很酷、很贴心、很好。好吧，安吉拉，我们知道那是谁干的。我们知道是谁做的。菲尔。那是菲尔。对。我都快哽咽了。我知道。
Because, you know, we lost Phil last year. He passed away. And yet as we do this rewatch, I just continue to think of him. Yeah. Yeah, me too. And with this story and with the card tower, that was Phil. Yeah. You know, and
因为，你知道的，我们去年失去了菲尔。他去世了。然而当我们进行这次重温时，我依然不断地想起他。对。对，我也是。通过这个故事还有纸牌屋，那都是菲尔。对。你知道的，还有
the sandwich with the pipe in it, it's coming up. That's Phil. But you know, Ange, when I was on Splitting Up Together, they wanted my character to sometimes wear glasses, but not my glasses. And originally, they just gave me some glasses with glass in them. And every time we would finish a scene, I would have to be like, do you know who has my real glasses?
那个夹着管子的三明治，等下就会讲到。那是菲尔。不过你知道的，安吉，当我拍《分居风暴》时，他们希望我的角色偶尔戴眼镜，但不是我自己的眼镜。最初，他们只是给我一些镜片是普通玻璃的眼镜。每次拍完一场戏，我都得问，你们知道谁拿着我的真眼镜吗？
Do we know where my real glasses are? And I ended up losing my real glasses several times. Because I would take them off and put them down on a shelf on set and then put my fake glasses on. And so in the second season they had my quote unquote show glasses made with my prescription and it changed everything because then I could read my script in between scenes. And so when Chris told this story, I did also think of that like, yes, yes, Chris, I have been there too. I know what that feels like. But how to his point, lovely that they did it for a guest star.
你知道我的真眼镜在哪儿吗？我最后把真眼镜弄丢了好几次。因为我会把它们摘下来放在片场的架子上，然后换上我的假眼镜。所以在第二季的时候，他们按照我的视力处方帮我制作了所谓的“剧组眼镜”，这改变了一切，因为这样我就可以在两场戏的间隙看剧本了。所以当克里斯讲完这个故事时，我也想到了这一点，那就是，没错，没错，克里斯，我也经历过。我知道那种感觉是什么样的。但就像他说的，他们能为客串演员做到这一地步，真的是太美好了。
I know. That was your show. I know. You were a series regular and you did have glasses. Till season two. Yeah. It was just one of those things where it was like, hey, we just realized we could put my prescription in these glasses. Everyone's like, oh, yeah. realized we could put my prescription in these glasses. Everyone's like, oh yeah.
我知道。那是你们的剧。我知道。你是剧组常驻演员，而且你本来就戴眼镜。直到第二季。对。这只是其中一件事，就好像，嘿，我们刚意识到我们可以把我的视力处方做进这些眼镜里。每个人都觉得，哦，对。意识到我们可以把我的视力处方做进这些眼镜里。每个人都觉得，哦，对。
Oh yeah. Now you can see. But you know, Phil being Phil, he thought of it. Thought of it right away. Yep. Should we go to crazy lunch with Jim and Stanley and Phyllis? Oh my gosh, this is hilarious. Talk about at the top of their game, Leslie and Phyllis in this scene. First of all, Stanley is in no rush to talk,
哦，对。现在你能看见了。但你知道的，菲尔不愧是菲尔，他想到了这一点。马上就想到了。没错。我们要不要去看看吉姆、斯坦利和菲莉丝那场疯狂的午餐？哦天哪，这太搞笑了。说到在这场戏里处于巅峰状态的莱斯利和菲莉丝。首先，斯坦利一点也不急着说话，
and he just wants to order surf and turf with an extra side of surf. They're gonna really run up this bill. Phyllis wants to know how much wine they have in the whole restaurant. No, kind of wine. How much? Yes. Well, location alert, we shot this at Delmonico's on Ventura Boulevard.
他只想点海陆大餐，还要额外加一份海鲜。他们这是要把账单吃爆啊。菲莉丝想知道整家餐厅有多少酒。不，是哪种酒。有多少？对。好吧，拍摄地点警报，我们是在范图拉大道上的德尔莫尼科餐厅拍的。
I think this is the same place that Michael ordered his Gabagool. Oh. same restaurant. And the waiter was played by guest star Noah Blake. And I think what this scene tells us is that Jim has an uphill battle here. Yeah, it's going to be a long lunch. It is. Oscar now brings Angela a cookie, and she calls him an angel. All right, come on, Oscar.
我觉得这跟迈克尔点他的“加巴古”是同一家店。哦。同一家餐厅。那个服务员由客串明星诺亚·布莱克饰演。我觉得这场戏告诉我们的是，吉姆在这儿面临着一场硬仗。对，这将是一顿漫长的午餐。确实如此。奥斯卡现在给安吉拉拿来一块饼干，而她称他为天使。行了，拜托，奥斯卡。
Fine, I get it that maybe her complaining about the thermostat didn't tip you off, but Angela just called you an angel. Come on. Yes, I think normally if you handed Angela a cookie that large, yeah, she would comment on it, right? Yeah, she'd be like, thank you, why is it so big? Or she'd say, why are you giving me a cookie? You never give me a cookie. I don't want this. Exactly.
好吧，我懂了，也许她抱怨恒温器没有给你敲响警钟，但安吉拉刚刚叫你天使诶。拜托。对，我想通常如果你递给安吉拉那么大一块饼干，是的，她会对它评头论足一番，对吧？对，她会说，谢谢，为什么它这么大？或者她会说，你为什么给我饼干？你从来不给我饼干。我才不要这个。没错。
When did they start making cookies like this? I don't like it. It has nuts. There'd be something. Something. There'd be something. But she calls him an angel and as he walks away, she crushes the cookies into her hands.
他们什么时候开始做这种饼干了？我不喜欢。里面有坚果。总会有说辞的。总会有。总会有说辞的。但她叫他天使，而在他走开时，她把饼干在手里捏碎了。
Which Dwight notices. Yes, he's putting all the pieces together because up until this point, he didn't know who this person was that Trevor had to take out. Well, Angela, we got a fan question. People wanna know how many cookies did you have to smash? Do you remember?
德怀特注意到了这一点。是的，他正在把所有线索拼凑起来，因为直到这一刻，他都不知道特雷弗要除掉的人究竟是谁。好吧，安吉拉，我们收到了一个粉丝提问。大家想知道你捏碎了多少块饼干？你还记得吗？
I don't remember, but it was, I think we did more than one take, so it was probably three or so. I'm sure Phil had a whole basket of them standing by. Exactly. And the one thing they wanted is for me to crush it and for it to just kind of fall off my hands into the trash. That was all scripted.
我不记得了，但我觉得，我们大概拍了好几条，所以可能拍了三次左右吧。我敢肯定菲尔旁边肯定备着一整篮饼干。没错。他们唯一的要求就是让我把它捏碎，然后让饼干渣从我手里掉进垃圾桶里。这些都是剧本里写好的。
And that was, I would say, of all the scenes that I had to do for this episode. That was the hardest one for me to ground in reality. Crumbling the cookie with this. Yes. Yeah. Because I just thought Angela wouldn't want to get her hands messy. Like she'd be like, Oh yeah.
而且我可以说，在我为这一集必须拍摄的所有戏份中。那是我觉得最难跟现实接轨的一场。用这个把饼干揉碎。是的。对。因为我当时想，安吉拉根本不想弄脏自己的手。她会觉得，哦，天哪。
She'd be like, I'm very annoyed at you. In fact, I'm incredibly pissed off at you, but I'm not going to get this crap all over my hands. I guess that tells you how incredibly pissed she was. How she was willing to dirty her hands. Yeah, she's super pissed. Well, now we're in the stairwell and- The secret stairwell.
她会觉得，我对你非常恼火。事实上，我对你气炸了，但我才不会把这破玩意儿弄得满手都是。我想这说明了她究竟有多么气急败坏。以至于她甚至愿意弄脏自己的双手。对，她气疯了。好吧，现在我们在楼梯间——秘密楼梯间。
The secret stairwell. The secret stairwell. Where Jim could have taken any of his- Nope, Jim's not gonna go there. But Oscar is. Yeah, and he's on the phone. He's assuring the senator that they are A-okay. Yeah, Angela doesn't know a thing.
秘密楼梯间。秘密楼梯间。吉姆本可以走任何一个——不，吉姆才不会去那儿。但奥斯卡去了。对，他正在打电话。他向参议员保证一切都好。对，安吉拉什么都不知道。
Dwight, of course, is lurking and has overheard the whole thing. He now knows. Dun dun dun. Dun dun dun. Well, lady, I think we should take a break. And when we come back, I have some tower stats for you. Oh, I love tower stats. I don't even know what a tower stat is, but I'm so excited. All right, we are back and Pam is going to walk into the annex and see everybody building this giant tower. And there's all this camaraderie and you can tell she's kind of like, I think she's maybe looking for a reason
德怀特当然在暗中窥探，把这一切都听得一清二楚。他现在知道了。当当当。当当当。好吧，女士，我想我们该休息一下了。等我们回来后，我有些关于纸牌屋的数据要告诉你。哦，我最喜欢纸牌屋数据了。我甚至不知道什么是纸牌屋数据，但我太兴奋了。好吧，我们回来了，帕姆走进附楼，看到大家都在搭这座巨型纸牌屋。大家充满了 camaraderie（同甘共苦的情谊），你能看出她心里大概在想，我觉得她可能在找借口
to not have to work on her painting right now. I think she's procrastinating. She is. But she's also very interested in this group activity that looks like a lot of fun. The tower is getting taller and taller and Kevin wants to put two cards at the tippity top and everyone's like Kevin be careful be careful and you can guess what happens. He knocks the whole thing down but they vow to start over.
现在不用去画画了。我觉得她在拖延。确实如此。但她也对这个看起来非常有趣的集体活动很感兴趣。纸牌屋越搭越高，凯文想在最顶端放两张牌，大家都说凯文小心点小心点，然后你大概能猜到发生了什么。他把整座塔都撞倒了，但他们发誓要重新开始。
They're gonna go again yeah well we got a lot of fan questions about this tower Alison M from Shelby North Carolina said please explain how the tower of complaint cards was made. said, please explain how the Tower of Complaint cards was made. How did you get the tower to stay put? How was it reconstructed between takes? And Jessica N from Rochester, New York said, do you know if there were any structures that were possibly glued together for some of the scenes? Or were they all legit card structures that just didn't make it through some of the takes?
他们要重来，对，好吧，我们收到了很多关于这座塔的粉丝提问。来自北卡罗来纳州谢尔比的艾莉森·M.说，请解释一下投诉卡纸牌屋是怎么制作的。说，请解释一下投诉卡纸牌屋是怎么制作的。你们是怎么让纸牌屋立住不动的？在不同的拍摄镜头之间它是怎么重建的？来自纽约州罗切斯特的杰西卡·N.说，你知道是否有些结构为了某些镜头可能被胶水粘合在一起了吗？还是它们全都是货真价实的纸牌结构，只是没能挺过某些镜头的拍摄？
They had to have been glued together. They were. Yeah. This had to have been glued together. They were. Yeah. This was such an elaborate prop actually. Kudos again to Phil Shea. Steve Burgess said that we had about six different versions of the tower in various stages. And then when I was talking with Brent,
它们肯定是用胶水粘在一起的。就是这样的。对。这绝对是用胶水粘起来的。就是这样的。对。这其实是一个非常精致的道具。再次向菲尔·谢伊致敬。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，我们大约有六个不同阶段的纸牌屋版本。然后当我跟布伦特聊天时，
he reminded me that they built it in layers. So there would be like the bottom layer that was all glued together. And then we could add like another layer that was all glued together. I do remember that, that they would carry them in on almost like this, I don't know, like a tray, like a big flat piece of plywood they would carry in a layer at a time. Yes. And Steve Burgess actually sent me a bunch of pictures of us posing around the towers. So you can put those in stories, Angela. But Brent said there was one exception, you know, the scene when Kevin has to knock the tower down. That was a real Tower of Cards. And it took a very
他提醒我，它们是一层一层搭建起来的。所以会有一个用胶水粘在一起的最底层。然后我们可以加上另一层，也是用胶水粘好的。我确实记得这一点，他们会把它们搬进来，几乎就像是用这个，我不知道，就像一个托盘，一块很大的平整胶合板，一次搬上来一层。是的。而且史蒂夫·伯吉斯确实发给我一堆我们在纸牌屋周围摆造型的照片。所以你可以把它们发到快拍里，安吉拉。但布伦特说有一个例外，你知道的，就是凯文不得不把纸牌屋撞倒的那场戏。那是一个真正的纸牌屋。建好它花了
long time to build. We filmed that in two parts. Brent said we did six takes of the scene right up until the moment when Kevin knocks the tower down. Then we did one take of him knocking the tower down. And then we did six takes of the second half of the scene when the cards were all splayed out. So he only had to knock the tower down once, but this was really important because you didn't know where the cards were gonna go when they fell. So it was kind of like an impossible continuity thing to try to recreate the cards falling. So that's why once they fell, we just left them
很长时间。我们分两部分拍摄了那场戏。布伦特说，从凯文把纸牌屋撞倒前的那一刻起，我们拍了六条。然后拍了一条他把纸牌屋撞倒的镜头。接着，我们在纸牌散落一地的时候又拍了六条后半场的戏。所以他只需要把纸牌屋撞倒一次，但这真的很重要，因为你不知道纸牌倒下时会飞到哪里去。所以这有点像是一个不可能完成的连戏任务，去试图重现纸牌倒下的样子。这就是为什么一旦它们倒了，我们就让它们留在
where they were and we did the end of the scene six times. Shout out to Brian Baumgartner because this is yet another time where he has to get it basically in one take. He had to spill that whole pot of chili and then one little area and then now he has to knock down this tower of cards and not mess it up. Yeah. You know, like what if he hit the middle by accident or, you know. Yes, if it hadn't fallen correctly, we would have had to wait for them to build the whole thing again in order to get the fall right. And then of course the subsequent takes afterwards.
原地，然后把戏的结尾拍了六遍。向布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳致敬，因为这又是另一个镜头，他基本上必须一条过。他得把整锅辣椒洒在一个小区域里，而现在他必须撞倒这座纸牌屋，还不能搞砸。对，万一他不小心撞到了中间或者别的什么。是的，如果没有正确倒塌的话，我们可能不得不等他们把整座塔重新搭好才能拍对倒塌的镜头。然后当然还有随后的那些补拍镜头。
Way to go, Brian. Way to go, Brian. I would like to share that someone is really noticing how sweet Pete is. Yeah. When Kevin knocks it all down and everyone's upset at him Pete says you know what? He made a mistake and isn't that what that whole tower is about anyway? And he gives Kevin a fist bump and he says let's get back to work Aaron is all smiles and there was a deleted talking head
干得好，布赖恩。干得好，布赖恩。我想分享的是，有人真的注意到了皮特有多温柔。对。当凯文把一切都撞倒，每个人都生他的气时，皮特说，你知道吗？他犯了个错误，而这不正是整个纸牌屋的意义所在吗？然后他跟凯文击了个拳，说我们回去工作吧。艾伦满脸笑容，而且有一个被删掉的单人采访，
Where Aaron talks about Pete and I want you to hear it Pete really sticks up for the underdog and in my book That's the best dog to stick up for the underdog and in my book that's the best dog to stick up for. The little dog that's underneath all the other dogs, way at the bottom. So yeah, good guy this Pete. I like this guy. Oh my gosh, I love that definition of underdog. I love the idea that there's a pile of dogs and there's a little guy. Tiny one underneath all one underneath all of them. At the bottom. Gotta get them out of there.
在采访中艾伦谈到了皮特，我想让你们听听。皮特真的很为弱者说话，在我看来，那才是最棒的为弱者说话的方式。最底下的那只小狗，压在所有其他狗下面，在最底层。所以，是的，这小伙子皮特真不错。我喜欢这家伙。天哪，我太喜欢对“弱者”的这种定义了。我喜欢这种想象，有一堆狗，而最底下有个小家伙。所有狗都压在最底下的那一只。得把它从下面救出来。
You know, another thing that Pete says is, come on, who in here hasn't gotten a complaint or made a mistake? And Pam raises her hand. She's never had a complaint against her. Not ever? With all the pranks she's done with Jim over the years? Dwight hasn't filed a complaint. Well, I think it's customer complaint. Oh, yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Okay. Okay. Yes. I'm sure there's
你知道，皮特说的另一句话是，拜托，在座的谁没收到过投诉或者犯过错？帕姆举起了手。她从来没收到过对她的投诉？一次也没有？带着她这些年和吉姆一起搞过的所有恶作剧？德怀特难道没提交过投诉吗？嗯，我觉得那是客户投诉。哦，对。是的。对。是的。好吧。好吧。是的。我确信
been files of Dwight complaints. Oh, yeah, you're right. So now the tower has been rebuilt and it is almost up to the ceiling. Yeah. And they've run out of cards. There's no more complaints. They just need one more complaint to make it to the ceiling. So Pam is going to volunteer to get a complaint. Meredith doesn't buy it. She says, you know what, Pam? She wouldn't fart on a butterfly. And then Jenna, the way you as Pam said the line, I can't even relate to that impulse.
肯定堆满了针对德怀特的投诉档案。哦，对，你说得对。现在纸牌屋已经重建好了，几乎快顶到天花板了。对。而且他们把牌用完了。再也没有投诉卡了。他们只需要最后一张投诉卡就能碰到天花板了。于是帕姆主动提出去弄一张投诉来。梅雷迪思才不信呢。她说，你知道吗，帕姆？她连对蝴蝶放个屁都舍不得。然后詹娜，你作为帕姆说那句台词的方式，我简直无法理解那种冲动。
It was so funny the way you said it. Well, one thing I remember from this particular scene was that the first time we had that what was going to be the tallest tower, Greg said it wasn't tall enough. What? Yeah, he said, I want the top card to touch the ceiling. He's like, that's when they know they've done it. I have to say, I agree with that. That feels like, okay, we've literally reached the ceiling. Yes.
你当时说的那句话太搞笑了。好吧，我从这场戏里记得的一件事是，当我们第一次搭出那个将成为最高纸牌屋的东西时，格雷格说它还不够高。什么？对，他说，我要让最顶上的牌碰到天花板。他说，只有那样他们才知道自己做到了。我必须说，我同意这一点。那种感觉就像是，好吧，我们实实在在地碰到了天花板。是的。
Well, Pam is definitely part of the camaraderie now because everyone is chanting, Pam, Pam, Pam, Pam. Except maybe someone in the warehouse would be chanting, Pat, Pat, Pat. Very true. Well, back at Jim's lunch, Phyllis is, what would you call it? She's looking at her hands.
好吧，帕姆现在绝对融入了这个大家庭，因为每个人都在齐声高喊，帕姆，帕姆，帕姆，帕姆。也许除了仓库里可能有人在喊，帕特，帕特，帕特。确实如此。好吧，回到吉姆的午餐，菲莉丝正在，你管这叫什么？她正在看着自己的双手。
She's seeing the passage of time. I thought Phyllis was so brilliant in this scene. She says, you know what? I don't know where the years went. Cause sometimes when I look at my hands, I don't even recognize them. And she goes, who's hands are these? And then she kind of folds them into her body.
她看到了时间的流逝。我觉得菲莉丝在这场戏里简直太绝了。她说，你知道吗？我不知道这些岁月都去哪儿了。因为有时当我看着自己的双手时，我甚至认不出它们了。她说，这到底是谁的手？然后她把手抱在胸前。
And she's like, they're not my hands. I don't know. And Jim's like, oh gosh, I'm not getting anywhere. Phyllis is so drunk. You know what this scene made me think of? I remember, I think I must have been in like my mid 40s. One morning I looked down at my hands and I got like immediately emotional because my
她说，这不是我的手。我不知道。吉姆就觉得，哦天哪，我一点进展也没有。菲莉丝醉得太厉害了。你知道这场戏让我想起了什么吗？我记得，我当时大概四十岁左右吧。有一天早上我低头看着自己的手，瞬间变得情绪激动，因为我的
hands looked just like my mother's hands. And I thought one day she's not going to be here anymore, but she's always going to be in my hands. I'm going to see her and I do see her when I look at my hands even now. It's so special to me. Yeah. Yeah. I started looking more and more like my mother as I get older, even in my face and everything like that. Growing up, I thought I didn't really look like
手看起来跟我母亲的手一模一样。然后我想有一天她将不在了，但她永远都会活在我的双手里。我会看到她，哪怕现在当我看着自己的手时，我也能看到她。这对我有特别的意义。对。对。随着我年龄的增长，我越来越像我母亲了，甚至连脸和各方面都一样。从小到大，我还以为我长得不太像
either of my parents. So when Phyllis was giving this big speech about whose hands are these, I remember the day I felt like I went from having my hands to, oh my gosh, I have my mother's hands. Yeah. Yeah. No, I have my mother's hands. Yeah, yeah. No, I get that too.
My dad's index fingers turned in and so do mine. Yours do. Yeah. I never noticed that about you. Yeah, and he's- I see it. He's no longer here, but I think about that when I look at my hands.
Sorry, that was okay. This like, sorry everyone, we went real deep there for a second. We did, sorry. These are more of the things I think you think about as you age. You do, you do. Passage of time, like Phyllis is talking about.
Phyllis is having a moment like that. She is. Which is not helping Jim as he's trying to just get her to cover for him when he goes out of town. No, because how do you segue from that? Right? Could you imagine us having the conversation we just had about our hands and then Cassie had to walk in here and be like, so listen, are y'all going to be able to cover for?
Can you wrap it up? Right? Just bring up business. Yeah. Yeah, it's very difficult position he is in. Well, if you thought that was the worst it was going to be for Jim, it's not because in a later scene, Phyllis starts poking a fellow patron with a knife because she wants him to help her pry that ginormous decorative bottle that it looks like it's been super glued down to the banister.
But she wants to drink it. That reminded me of those bottles of wine they would put on the tables at the SAG awards. Right, the one that Matt Damon took. We got a fan question from Becca G in Morganfield, Kentucky, who said, The scene that makes me laugh the hardest and it only gets funnier every time, is when Jim Stanley and Phyllis go to lunch, every time Phyllis goes for that decorative wine, I cry from laughing so hard, those three were phenomenal in that scene. So good. So Brent told us that this shoot at the restaurant went so smoothly and so quickly that they got
ahead of schedule and they had time to write an extra scene on the spot and shoot it. And it was a scene where Stanley drags Jim into the kitchen and makes him pay the cook to create a custom dessert for the table. It's in deleted scenes. Part of it is in deleted scenes.
He just starts taking like plates of dessert off. He's in the kitchen in the back where they're plating things and Stanley just starts grabbing them. Brent said the scene was so funny, but unfortunately there was no room for it in the final cut. But I love that they were on set and they were like,
we gotta write something right now for these three. This is going so well. Back at Dundra Mifflin, Dwight has called Angela out to the parking lot and he tells her, I know who your target is, it's Oscar. Yeah. Well, she pretends like she doesn't know what Dwight is talking about, but he says, your nostrils are flaring and they tell another story. Yeah, you're lying because of your nostrils. He says, your naughty nostrils.
Well, of course, I had to look up facial signs of lying. Is flaring nostrils one of them? No. Oh! No, Dwight is not right. Unless somewhere else on the internet, there's something to prove me wrong. No, I think Dwight is right, but it's just a particular tell of Angela's, not in general.
The most common tells of facial lying are pursed lips, blushing, blinking, darting eyes, avoiding eye contact, face touching, covering your mouth, head shaking, and sweating. I knew that touching your face is a sign of lying. How? I remember that from my poker days. Oh.
Many of the things you mentioned are also poker tells for when someone is bluffing. Oh. Like flushing of the cheeks, but also like touching of the face. Interesting. Well, flared nostrils isn't on the list. I really liked Dwight in the scene, because he reminds Angela that the first person
to break her marriage vows is her. It was the two of them. That's right. And she goes, well, you might be right, but it's too late. He's here. The plan is in motion. Yeah, they look over. There's Trevor's van and it's empty.
Trevor is on the move. Dwight is now panicked. He's got to find Oscar. So he rushes into the office. Dwight is now panicked. He's got to find Oscar. So he rushes into the office, he grabs him, he's making up an excuse to get him down to the warehouse. Meanwhile, just as they get out of there, Trevor enters with a sub sandwich, like a big sandwich, and he has a metal pipe in it. You can clearly see the metal pipe. It's so funny. He announces that he has a sandwich for Oscar Martinez,
and Kevin says, I am Oscar Martinez. And then Angela comes in and goes, no, no, no. And tells Kevin there are donuts. So Kevin will get out of the way. Well, we asked Chris if he ever got recognized for being on the office, and he has a very funny story. And he referenced this sandwich delivery moment specifically. As far as if I get recognized as Trevor from the office,
holy, it's nonstop to the point where I've said, and again, to Angela, Jenna, I say it to you as well. Like I've kept in touch with Rain to a degree and I'm like man I don't know how I Don't know how you like Go out for dinner or go to the airport because I was on two episodes of this damn show and I got stopped all the time And it's been so many years. It's been I think over a decade at this point and to be clear I had an HBO special, stand-up special.
I had a show called The Chris Gether Show. I've been on other things, Parks and Rec. I've been on Conan a bunch of times as myself, where they're saying my name. I've been on Inside AB Schumer. Like, I don't wanna list a million credits, but I've had a good career as a character actor. Nothing gets recognized more than just, hey, weren't you the guy with the pipe?
Weren't you the guy, the sandwich delivery guy? I get that all the time still. I would say if I get recognized, there's an 85% chance it's for the office. No joke, just last weekend, did stand up in San Francisco in Portland and my bag got pulled by TSA. And this is not an exaggeration at all. The TSA agent, he didn't say anything to me at first, but he patted down my chest and then my actual ass and testicles.
He touched my testicles with his hands, popped up and went, you're good to go. I love you on the office. That is not an exaggeration. Like a TSA agent fondled my testicles and then told me he really liked me as Trevor on the office. So it is hugely flattering to be part of something so meaningful that such a small part struck a chord with people. It's awesome.
It's an honor. I also sit here and I go, for those of you who were series regulars every episode for 10 years, God bless you all because I've had my nuts touched by a TSA agent who immediately then brought up the office. So I can't imagine what you all go through on a regular basis. Chris, I absolutely love that story. I mean, we both have so many versions of that story. It does happen all the time, but you just can't help but laugh. I mean, my goodness.
It's also the timing of when it happens. Like this guy just frisked you. Yes, exactly. And was like, by the way. Yes, and also because you guy just frisked you. And then was like, by the way. Yes. And also because you've been frisked, right? And you think you have anonymity while the frisking is happening? Yes. And then as you're leaving the frisk, you realize, oh, yes. Okay. That's just one example. Just one day. Of hundreds. There are truly so many examples, just like Chris's. Yes, there are. We have so many, but you know,
obviously we're so appreciative that people love the show, but sometimes the timing. Sometimes the timing could be better. Maybe mention it before the Frisk. I think you want it after the Frisk. I do think if you're gonna say something, do it after a Frisk. I think.
Yeah, okay. Right? Yeah, maybe so. I think so. Well, now Dwight and Oscar are in the warehouse and Dwight tells him what was going on, that they were gonna break his kneecaps. And he says, of all the gorgeous men
in the Scranton Wilkesbury area, why did you have to choose the father of Angela's child? Come on! Dwight is still trying to just get Oscar out of there. He rushes them out of the warehouse into the alleyway, and guess what? Trevor is right there, and he is determined for once follow-through with something.
So the three of them end up kind of scuffling, struggling over this pipe. Dwight and Oscar are trying to get it away from Trevor. Trevor's trying to complete the job for which he was hired. Oscar prevails! He gets the pipe! I asked Steve Burgess if we had a fight coordinator or a stunt coordinator for this fight, and he said no. No! They just let the three of them sort it out. Yeah.
Well, I asked Chris about this scene, and here's what he had to say. As far as the fight scene, I remember the day moving pretty quickly. I remember being pretty intimidated even though obviously everyone on set was so nice. But I felt like things could get wild. But it all went well. I remember being slightly different each time because we were kind of really wrestling around. I think I like that.
I like the idea of if we're going to do something physical and we're not supposed to be trained fighters, like we might as well go for it and see where our bodies go because that'll be natural. I also got the sense that rain was probably into that Oscar, I think, was probably the one who was the most reserved about, wait, what's exactly going to happen? And I think rain and I who rain and I have remained, you know, not super tight, but we touch base every couple of years just to see how the other one's doing and cross paths. And I do get the sense he and I both probably have a similar sense of, well, if we're doing some
scene that's supposed to be some crazy unplanned wrestling match, the easiest way to do it is just let's start wrestling. So that was pretty fun. Chris, I would confirm that that would be Reigns' take on that. 100%. Yes. I also asked Chris if any of his improvs made it into the episode, because you know, he was so funny. And yes, we got everything scripted and it was so well written. But there were these great moments of improvisation from him. And here's what he had to say. I do remember improvising a line in the fight with Oscar.
If I remember right, I run away and while I run away, I'm shouting something along the lines of I have masculinity issues. And that line was improvised. I remember being psyched that they used that. That is so fun. Chris also had talked about just how amazing the writing was. Yeah. And he said like one of the reasons he was so tickled
to get an improv line in was because he knew it was gonna have to really be good in order to make it, because all the scripted stuff was so good. Yeah. Well, we got a fan question about this scene from Carly P. and Cesar Illinois. And Carly said this, when Dwight, Oscar and Trevor are fighting over the pipe,
there are people passing by in the background, on the street. Were these just actual passerby's or were they staged to walk past at this point? Because they do not look concerned about three grown men rolling on the ground fighting over a lead pipe. Carly, I did not notice this at first. I went back and I rewatched the scene and I see this couple walk by. I think they're just two people who walked out of the street. Carly, I went back and looked as well. They are 100% just two people walking down the street. I think the other thing that's going on here is that we had been filming this show for nine years at this location and there were other businesses right next to us. And at this point, they just
knew, oh, it's that TV show. So I think when they saw three men like t this point, they just knew, oh, it's that TV show. So I think when they saw three men like tussling, they were like, oh, they're doing, they're filming something, I don't know. That is exactly what I thought as well. Well, now it's Pam's turn to try to get a complaint, right? Yep. Erin and Nellie and Creed are really encouraging her
to fail, they say you gotta think like a scumbag. Creed shows her, but then just looks off into space. It's like this, Pam calls a client and does your mama's so fat joke and hangs up on them. Yeah. Aaron's phone immediately rings and she takes the message and guess what? They lost a client.
Woohoo! Everyone's like woohoo, but then they're like, oh wait, crap, we lost a client. Everyone's like, woohoo! But then they're like, oh, wait, crap, we lost a client. We just wanted a complaint. A complaint. Jenna, you're so good in this scene. I thought you just were great. And you know what?
Brent thought so too. Here's what he had to say. The Tower of Complaints subplot is one of those big group stories that becomes so useful to the writers in the later seasons of The Office when we have 14 characters in the show and we have to give them all something to do. So this one takes up eight characters
and that's really useful to the writers. What was so fun about this episode was how funny Jenna was in it. So often Pam's character is the emotional heart of the story and her relationship with Jim is the romantic subplot that is driving so much of the series, but it is so delightful when Jenna gets to be funny and the writers took a lot of pleasure in figuring out how to make this proper character funny by forcing her to fail.
And you'll notice that in the final prank phone call that she makes to lose a client, the laugh doesn't come on the yo mama joke. It comes on Pam having to over explain the yo mama joke because she's never had to deliver an insult like this before. It's a classic example of the laugh coming not on the cleverness of the joke itself but on the performance of the actor. And Jenna just nails it. Lady, my favorite thing about Brent sending an audio clips is that they always include like high praise for you and I.
I know Brent. And they make me feel so good about myself. Brent, thank you so much. But one of the other things I really appreciate about Brent's perspective on episodes is he always takes it back to what moves the story, what makes the joke happen. I can just hear what a great teacher he is.
Cause he's so right. The thing that's funny about it, isn't the yo mama joke. It's Pam getting so flustered and trying so earnestly to really be off-putting? Yes. Speaking of, Brent is a teacher. He teaches comedy writing classes. Yes. And you can sign up for his classes at BrentForster.com.
And you know, I'll put it in stories. Yes, she will. Well, this storyline ends with everybody back in the Annex, and they put Pam's complaint on the top of the tower and it's almost brushing the ceiling tiles and everyone cheers. Yeah, Pam saved the day. Yes, what we learned a little more information about how her insult was truly terrible because I guess this woman had recently passed away and had struggled with obesity her whole life.
The client's mother had just recently passed away, which is why it wasn't just a complaint card. It was, you don't get our business anymore. Yes, and Pam wants you to know, I did not know any of that information. I am so very sorry. Of course not. But everyone's happy.
They built a tower. That's what they did that day. So simple, so simple. And lovely. We also got a fan question about this scene from Roy L. L. in Boise, Idaho, who said, I have been waiting for years to submit this. It always makes me so happy
when we can like answer a question for someone that has been like years in this making years waiting for the episode. Yeah, same All right, here's the question when Creed is congratulating Pam for her first customer complaint. Why is he in gray sweatpants? I also noticed he has his business shirt tucked into his sweatpants. This is such a funny detail Well, Royale, I noticed this too and I was curious, so I went to the shooting draft and I found the answer. It was actually explained at the very top of the episode and here's how the script read. Jim and Pam walk in for the day. Pam is wearing painting clothes, a paint-flexed sweatshirt
and jeans. Dwight says, well, it finally happened, Pam stopped caring. Creed says, welcome aboard, Pam. And in the stage direction, it says, Creed is wearing sweat pants and crocs. Oh, wow, that's great. And then Pam says, these are my painting clothes. Isn't it funny how you trim out one line? Yeah. And now for this whole episode, we have the mystery of why is Creed wearing sweatpants? I bet Creed was so happy to be wearing sweatpants and crocs all week. He was probably like, we should make this a week thing.
A clean thing. Back in the alleyway, the guys have stopped tussling and Angela now has suddenly appeared behind Oscar. Yeah. And he's gonna yell at her. He's gonna be like, I cannot believe you hired someone to beat me with a pipe. And he says, look, what I did was wrong and I have to live with that every day,
but your husband is gay. And he was gay when you married him. And Angela's like, no. And Oscar says, Angela, until you face that, you're gonna be confused and angry for all the wrong reasons. But if you wanna blame me for the whole thing, go ahead. I won't stop you. Hit me. You have my blessing. Hit me." And Angela's like, okay, she grabs the pipe. I know, but you won't let go of it.
And she says, are you going to let go of it because part of the blame is definitely on you. And then Oscar says, Angela, it's a lead-freaking pipe. And then Angela just kicks him. How did that work, Angela? Did you just fake kick him? Did he have a pad? I kicked him and he had a pad on his shin. Like a shin guard. He had a shin guard, but I really kicked him.
Okay, because it looked like a real kick. It was. Okay. And then Angela very emotionally says, you were supposed to be my friend. Yeah. And then later, Angela is crying on a bench outside and Dwight joins her.
And she says, I just feel so stupid. I sit next to him every day. So lady, this is a line that's quoted to me a lot. This is one of those lines and rain gets it too. You're not stupid, Jazz is stupid. And then I say, Jazz is stupid. I mean, just play the right notes. It's such a funny thing to say. And then Dwight says, I know, you're going to be okay, monkey. And then the last
couplet of dialogue was completely improvised. About Trevor? I say, I don't like your friend Trevor. And then Rain says, I don't like him either. And yet I really like him. Oh my gosh, I can't believe that was improvised. Yep. And it made it in. And I was so tickled when I saw it. Because, you know, with me crying and Dwight puts his arm around me, they left the camera there for a bit. Yeah. And so I just said, I don't like your friend Trevor.
Such a funny thing to say. And then Dwight has such a great response. His great response is perfection. We got a fan question from Jennifer C. in Colorado Springs, Colorado, who said, this is something I've wondered for years. Does Mike sure hate jazz? Oh.
I know he didn't write this episode, but this theme pops up in a lot of his projects. And then Jennifer cites all these projects, The Good Place, Season 1, Episode 9. Someone says, ugh, I hate jazz. It's like we get it. Wrap it up Elton John. In Parks and Recreation, season five episode 12, someone says,
you'd really want to get to know the guy, right? You'd want to know his personality, his favorite season of friends, whether he hates jazz. Hopefully he does. There is a theme here. Yes. And then jazz is stupid. Just play the right notes.
Jennifer said, these are just three examples, but there are so many more. Please explain. So one of my favorite things with our podcast is to reach out to people. Please tell me you texted Mike, sure about this. I did. What did he say? He wrote back, ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha ha. You can tell Jennifer, I don't hate jazz. I didn't even write all of those jokes. But comedy writers like to pick on jazz because like most art forms, it has a certain group of adherents who like to lecture you on why it's so amazing and so cool and so special. Mike said kind of like the Ryan Gosling character in La La Land where he explains jazz to John Legend. Mike said comedy writers in general have a disdain for anything that causes people to wax poetic or why you just don't get something. And he said jazz is one
of those things. What a perfect answer. I know. I love that. Well, I love that Jennifer Keaton on on this joke about jazz. Yeah keeps popping up You know, we also got quite a few people who wrote in and said wait So Angela likes babies who play jazz for posters, but not actual jazz. Yes I saw those I think it's not so much about babies playing jazz that Angela liked about the poster,
but just the fact that they were dressed up in like a little fedora and they had instruments. It's like when you dress up your pets. I think Angela likes babies dressed as like adult things. Yes. So like a favorite Halloween costume for Angela would be like a baby dressed like an old man. Or a baby dressed like an old man. Or a baby dressed like an old-timey pilot. Yes.
Or a race car driver. That's right. Yeah. Kind of like how you like animals dressed as other animals. Yes. Right. Like, I love nothing more than a bunny rabbit dressed as a bear stuffed animal. Right.
This is such a weird thing that I like that. What is that about? I don't know. I don't know, we like what we like. We like what we like. Well, Jim is finally pulling into the parking lot now with Stanley and Phyllis. They're asleep in the back seat.
They've eaten everything, they've drank everything. And Jim is just gonna kind of tuck him in. He's taking his coat, putting it over, fill us like a blanket and she says, of course we're gonna cover for you, Jimmy. We love you guys. So sweet. So sweet and she calls him Jimmy, which I love.
And then we're gonna go to the warehouse and guess what? There is paint on the wall. It's happening and I have to tell you, there was a very sweet deleted scene between Pam and the senator that happened here. So in the shooting draft, there was a scene where the senator shows up to the bullpen with coffee. I guess he's just stopped by, right?
No one's in the bullpen except for Daryl and he says, hey, where is everyone? And Daryl says, I think Angela's in the warehouse. And the senator goes, okay, well, if you see Oscar, will you tell Oscar that I stopped by with coffee for Angela? And Darrell gets this look like what? And Darrell's like, or I could just tell Angela herself. And the senator goes, oh, yeah, I guess that would work too. And Daryl has this look of like, what was that about? And then the next scene is the senator walking into the warehouse and he sees Pam
No one's in the bullpen except for Daryl and he says, hey, where is everyone? And Daryl says, I think Angela's in the warehouse. And the senator goes, okay, well, if you see Oscar, will you tell Oscar that I stopped by with coffee for Angela? And Daryl gets this look like what? And Daryl's like, or I could just tell Angela herself. And the senator goes, oh, yeah, I guess that would work too. And Daryl has this look of like, what was that about? And then the next scene is the senator walking into the warehouse and he sees Pam
and they have this exchange. And I really loved it because I feel like Pam has locked into something about herself. Hello Pam. Senator. I thought you were the office manager. No, I'm an artist. And I work in an office. How about that? I love that!
She just owns it. She does. I'm an artist. I also do this other thing, but that's where my heart is. Yeah. You know, we had a fan question from Bethany N in Australia who said, Who actually painted the mural? Well, Bethany, all the paint that you see on the wall in this
episode was me. I painted it. Later, it was not me at all. But I actually got to put paint up on the wall for this one. Well, this episode is going to end with a tag Dwight and Angela are meeting with Toby. Yeah, for some reason, Toby is who Dwight goes to for any kind of like questions about relationships or sex. He goes to Toby. Yes, in the episode, Sexual Harassment Dwight sits down with Toby. Yeah. Remember, and he's asking about a woman's body. A woman's pleasure areas. Yes. Yes, so for whatever reason, this is the go-to, Toby. Toby.
And he's always very kind and thoughtful. Yes. Well, Dwight and Angela have a lot of questions for Toby about basically Oscar and the senator and how things are going down. Right. Brent shared with us something about this scene. He said that it was Paul Lieberstein's idea
that we speak in a whisper to make it seem that much more serious and ridiculous. That was a good choice. Well guys, there you have it. The target. Gosh, I loved this episode. I absolutely loved doing these scenes with Oscar. You know, the show had a lot of love triangles and this was one of my favorites.
Well, a big thank you to Brent Forrester and Steve Burgess for sending us all your behind the scenes info. And a big thank you to Chris Gethard for sharing with us about his time playing Trevor. Oh my gosh, what an amazing character. And Chris has so many great things he's working on. You can hear him on his podcast, Beautiful Anonymous. He also wrote a book, Dad at Peace.
And Chris is the creative mind behind Wellness Together's newest program, Laughing Together. Chris says they're very excited to announce their efforts to expand advocacy, awareness, and access to mental health for students. And you can learn all about it on their website, laughingtogether.org. I'll share all of that in our stories. And of course, thank you to all of you for sending in your questions. I'm so glad we could answer so many of them that have been bugging you all for years in
this episode. We hope you have a great rest of your day and a great week, and we'll see you next week. See you then! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy and our associate producer is Ainsley
Bubbicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.